bonjour
bonsoir des rahim bonsoir pierre alors
tué le directeur général d'une société
de livraison à domicile que tu as créé
il ya maintenant un peu plus de deux ans
mais rien ne te prédestiné à faire ce
parcours il ya quelques années tu étais
simplement étudiants en écoles
d'ingénieurs et je crois que tu faisais
un petit boulot à l'époque
comme tous les étudiants étrangers qui
arrivent en france pour leur franche
dreams
on était en face d'un problématique de
l'embauché de d'emploi c'est qu'on
n'avait pas le droit de dépasser 20
heures de travail par semaine mon avis
on était justement limiter et
malheureusement cette limite de travail
d'horaires par semaine ça nous permet
pas d'avoir vraiment un revenu de
salaire équitable et du coup l'arrivée
des géants du secteur de la livraison de
repas à domicile c'était la seule
solution pour nous de de travailler plus
pour gagner plus et
j'applique est toujours un proverbe à
mon père si on n'a pas le choix de faire
ce qu'on aime et faut qu on aime ce
qu'on est en train de faire pour faire
après ce qu'on a ce qu'on aime et je
crois que ça a bien marché puisque tu as
été élu meilleur livre heures je pense
par cette plateforme où est
effectivement peu après deux ans et demi
de travail avec ses plates formes la
soute ou les conditions de travail c'est
de neige pluie
jour inouïe et
on a on a réussi à avoir après le le
respect des restaurateurs le respect des
clients et du coup les restaurateurs et
les clients ils ont voté avec une
satisfaction de 95 % pour moi pour être
élu meilleur livre heures c'est cette
plateforme là cette année par contre je
pense que au fur et à mesure au fil du
temps les conditions de travail se sont
dégradées de plus en plus et tu as
décidé à ce moment là de faire autre
chose
oui en fait j'avais vraiment
[Musique]
partager l'amour vers ce travail là est
vraiment convaincre pas mal de mes amis
pas mal de mon entourage pour rejoindre
la flotte de livreurs à domicile et que
c'est un travail qui a vraiment il ya de
l'avenir de dents et du coup les
premiers contrats c'était vraiment très
raisonnable on a bossé mais au fur et à
mesure du coup il y avait un chute du
contrat y conte était malheureusement
forcé à signer de nouveaux contrats et
du coup on était forcés à trouver une
alternative
comment on pourra je pourrais vraiment
garantir à tous ses amis là que j'ai
vraiment convaincu de rejoindre ses
flottes là que maintenant ils nous
voient autrement parce que c'est plate
forme là ils n'ont pas tenu leur parole
c'est de créer vraiment notre propre
travail créé notre propre plateforme et
à ce moment là tu as créé la société
quand tu as créé sa société il ya
quelque chose qui a vraiment tenu à
coeur tu as vraiment été marqué par le
mauvais traitement que la façon dont
traiter les employés ces plateformes et
à ce moment là tu as vraiment décidé de
mettre l'humain au coeur de la
plateforme comment est-ce que ça va
fonctionner et quel a été l'impact que
ça hue
on a été éduqué sur une éducation
basique la plupart des
des humains ils sont éduqués c'est
l'éducation sur des valeurs humaines et
de vraiment que le respect de lima où le
respect soit il est en malade soit il
est en situation de stress vraiment
mettre les valeurs humaines avant tout
avant le business avant l'argent 7 et
l'éducation de nos parents et du coup
c'était pas trop difficile pour nous de
vraiment se concentrer sur cette cette
base ceux de m les valeurs humaines au
sein de notre activité entrepreneuriale
et que vraiment prouver à ces géants la
con travaillons sur des valeurs humaines
on n'est pas obligé de exploiter les
personnes pour gagner plus d'argent et
c'est le cas on verra après que ç'a eu d
impact très positif pour la société mais
lors de la création tu investis d'abord
toutes les économies et à un moment
donné il te reste je crois que c'est 32
euros en poche pour finir le mois et
viennent faire vivre toi et ta famille à
ce moment là tu décide d'aller voir cinq
grandes banques de la région quelle a
été la réponse qu'elle pour déneiger way
tellement on était tellement engagé -
mon associé dans le projet vraiment où
on réfléchit pas thème on avait de
l'énergie en croyez vraiment ce qu'on
est en train de faire ce qu'on est train
de réaliser ça nous a pris à peu près
plus que dix mois de d'études de marché
de travail on dépensait sans compter
vraiment derrière nous du coup y avait
un petit soir une grosse facture à payer
par carte bancaire du coup j'ai payé
sans faire attention il me restait
combien sur le compte jusqu'à le monde
hommage vérifier je suis retrouvée je me
restait 32 euros pour eux et j'étais
c'était à peu près le 5 du mois le 6 du
coup c'était juste devait des mois et du
coup on a deux c'était la solution après
pour poser à pas mal des amis c'était
voir les banques est ce qu'ils peuvent
nous aider pour vraiment faire lancer ce
projet on n'avait pas besoin de beaucoup
on avait besoin 30000 euros pas plus
contacter les banques monde au bout de
deux jours les fils téléphoniques prend
des rendez-vous par la semaine prochaine
et tous les bons qu'ils avaient la même
réponse chaque il y avait chaque fois
que chacune des banques qui avaient une
réponse différente
mais avec une seule conclusion c'était
non malheureusement pourrez pas vous
suivre parmi ces réponses là il y avait
une banque n 10 malheureusement vos
étant un secteur qui est dominé par des
géants multinationales qui pèse des
milliards d'euros votre concept ça peut
pas marcher maintenant on vit dans un
monde c'est l'argent qui parlent
d'autres banques malheureusement votre
triste jour il est périmé dans trois
mois à peu par vous financer un
financement à moyen terme de 4 ans que
vous demandez c'est trop et du coup on a
fait en sorte de continuer avec nos
fonds propres de de miser et deviser sur
les valeurs humaines sur l'esprit des
nordistes et qui croient en notre projet
finalement les banques avaient plus peur
des géants que vous
quelque part c'est vrai il avait été là
à l'époque c'était pour eux
impossible qu' une petite start up qui
vient d'être naître pour concurrencer
les multinationales qui pourra avoir un
succès c'était pour eux c'était
impossible
alors deux ans plus tard tueur contact
ces mêmes banques pour faire un appel
d'offres pour lever des fonds et là la
réponse de ces cinq banques est
complètement différente puisqu'elle te
propose tout tout de suite de financer
tata start up qu'est ce qui a bien pu
changer pendant ces deux années qu'est
ce que tu as fait qui a tellement changé
la vision de ces banques
ce qui a changé au bout de deux ans je
pense pas que chez nous dans le monde
entier pendant deux ans il y avait des
grands changements on a passé par une
très grande crise sanitaire
malheureusement et du coup ces banques
là il ya deux ans en arrière vraiment le
projet nous on était pas on était encore
dans la peau des livreurs du qu'on
n'était pas assez matures vont assez
encadrée pour préparer un business plan
préparé un prévisionnel je le comprenais
quand même sur leurs réactions aux
premières car maintenant dans cette
situation là mais heureusement on a
rencontré des structures
d'accompagnement sur notre route on a
rencontré des personnes qui nous ont
guidés et des coachs qui nous a vraiment
accompagné d et cabinets d'experts
comptables qu'ils ont offert leurs
services pour nous accompagner dès que
des structures d'accompagnement des
structures d'état aussi qu'ils ont mais
qu'ils ont cru à ce projet là mais nous
ont pas aidés financièrement direct mais
plutôt avec un accompagnement
structurants et du coup dès que le
projet était très bien structurée nous
aussi aussi s'être fut au début qu'on a
eu des banques sami de l'énergie e.on ou
sa sacrée ya de l'adrénaline en ou deux
vraiment avec mon associé et qui a mais
vraiment qu'on dit vraiment il faut que
les prouve que ça peut marcher c'est pas
parce qu'on vit dans un monde que il est
dominé par l'argent que les valeurs
humaines on pourra les oublier
c'est tous les clients malheureusement
même et commandant cj en là mais à
l'intérieur quand il mange son repas il
sent qu'il ya quelque chose qui manque
elles sont que vraiment si elle n'a pas
le bon goût de ce repas là parce qu'il a
vu qu'il ya un livreur qui est exploité
qui lui a livré cette commande là et du
coup on s'est concentré sur ces valeurs
là d'accord alors on va revenir sur le
facteur humain dont tu as parlé tout à
l'heure tu as fait un système en fait
qui re qui est basé sur trois éléments
techniques
d'une part les restaurateurs et aux
sites et livreurs et est employé avec
ces trois éléments humains tu as
vraiment réussi à construire un système
qui a aussi parlé vraiment aux personnes
ici dans la région qui a parlé aux
personnes locales et ça fait une grande
partie de son succès est ce que tu peux
nous en dire un peu plus sur cette
partie nous a du coup je pense que tu as
cité quatre éléments les restaurateurs
livreurs les clients et nous du coup ces
quatre éléments c'est des humains du
coup on est délicate on est des humains
du concert on a mais ce centre là les
valeurs humaines du coup on a essayé de
vraiment chercher c'est quoi le modèle
économique qui peut répondre aux besoins
d'un livreur besoins d'un client ait
besoin d'un restaurateur et créé le
système vertueux qui permet à tous ces
éléments-là de travailler dignement ou
et correctement est vraiment de
permettre à chacun trouvé son morceau de
pain et permettre aux clients aussi de
manger avec la conscience tranquille
c'était juste ça on n'a rien fait
d'exceptionnel mais vraiment on a vu
vous juste rappeler c'est quoi on nous
on est quoi on est des humains ce qu on
doit se concentrer sur quoi sur des
valeurs humaines et mettre les humains
toujours comme je dis toujours au centre
de notre activité au centre votre
entrepreneur et ça fonctionne puisque
aujourd'hui la plateforme rencontre un
énorme succès dans la région je crois
d'ailleurs que tu as plateforme on
couvre plus de villes que les légions
est ce que c'est vrai ou est-ce que
c'est faux ouais c'est vrai on est la
seule plateforme maintenant dans la
région qui couvre plus que 50 villes
autour de lamelles et ça fait vraiment
plaisir que parce que c'est au début
qu'on a lancé vraiment comme j'ai dit
les bons qu'ils ont pas pu le suivre
malheureusement mais le client ils ont
pu le suivre on avait des clients au
début qui commande et chine ont vraiment
juste pour nous faire des dons pour nous
encourager vraiment bon courage pour
vous faites on n'avait pas cette
financement pour refinancer recruter des
services clients ça va recruter des
développeurs recruter des
graphistes on faisait tout le travail à
2,2 à partir du matin on commercialise
les restaurateurs le midi ont au livret
a à 2 mois et mon associé je suis un
vélo je réponds clients en même temps
sur le service client l'après-midi à
l'installation des restaurateurs le soir
en livraison non associés les sur son
vélo et il est aussi derrière son
portable il dirige son 100 pc depuis son
portable s'il ya des bugs en ligne et
tout ça c'était vraiment très chouette
au début hélas la couverture on a
retrouvé pendant le premier confinement
que les restaurateurs aient commencé à
nous demander qu'ils ont des habitants
qu'ils habitent dans la mède dans les
villes périphériques et qu'il n'arrive
pas à les joindre et du coup nous il y
avait des villes des routes il était
vide
malheureusement à cause des crises
sanitaires et du coup on s'est dit
pourquoi pas proposer d'autres services
à ses clients du coup on a augmenté le
rayon de livraison de cinq à vingt
kilomètres sans demander de commissions
supplémentaires aux restaurateurs et
sans demander de frais supplémentaires
aux clients pendant deux mois du coup on
a proposé aux restaurateurs qu'on va
faire ça que pour deux mois mais après
dès qu'on a trouvé ce succès là que les
clients ont répondu qu'ils habitent en
campagne qui habitons village qui
habitent dans les habitats cysoing
pérenchies qui peuvent profiter de ces
services là on s'est dit pourquoi pas le
garder pour tout le temps je crois
d'ailleurs que tu as un client qui est
dans la campagne que tu aime beaucoup
qui te commande énormément de deux plats
par par mois c'est
parmi nos clients
vip gold c'est qu'il n'a pas rejoignez
depuis le premier mois de lancement
qu'elle commandait chez nous dans sa
maison
sur l'île et dès qu'il a su comme quoi
on peut re a livré sur toute la région
du cou il habite à 17 km de lille dans
une petite d'un petit campagne et du
coup ils courent monde entre ses clients
particuliers qu'il commande entre 3 4000
euros par mois et du coup chaque fois il
satisfait ses clips ses invités chaque
fois qu'il ya un invité qui arrivent et
le dire regarde je connais quelque chose
je connais il ya une plate forme tiens
je te commande chez lui il commente pour
tout le monde mais au début il faisait
juste pour nous encourager pour nous
soutenir ces temps c'est un sacré
soutien quand même de la part d'un
particulier bien
je crois que tu es bon on va déjà
beaucoup parler d du côté humain de ta
société je crois que tu es très très
fier de tes employés de la façon de ce
petit travail est ce que tu veux dire un
petit mot pour eux ce soir
pour mes employés je les souhaite que
d'un bel avenir avec avec nous au pour
eux et tous nos employés je vais dire
100 % de nos employés 100 personnes non
salariées 100% de nos livreurs il croise
au projet là vraiment il travaille je le
sens je le vois il vaut tout le monde le
voit c'est que chaque élément il
travaille dans le projet dit parce qu'il
sait que c'est son propre projet et le
donne à fond tout le monde du coup nous
on a on s'est concentré sur l'aspect
social au début avant l'aspect technique
ou l'aspect financière et du coup c'est
celle là qui vraiment créer de l'énergie
au sein de nos employés qui a vraiment
donné 7,7 rayonnement à cette plateforme
et que on essayera de le vraiment le
faire découvrir toute la france à partir
du nord tout à fait puisque aujourd'hui
tu as je crois 50 villes déjà et tu vas
il ya beaucoup de villes qui te demande
de rejoindre beaucoup de metropolit au
hilton métropole qui le demandent il ya
beaucoup de restaurateurs partout en
france qui nous demande de venir laisse
courir vraiment beaucoup de livreur il
ya plus que trente mille livres
indépendant en france qui sont surtout
des contrats prétexte salariés déguisés
et du coup nous ont déjà
pour l'instant on se développe doucement
parce qu'on veut pas perdre la qualité
de service on peut pas perdre aussi les
engagements et les valeurs sur quoi on
s'est basés il ya près tout doucement
notre objectif c'est dans dix ans on
court toute la france très bien alors je
pense que le côté local est en fait un
atout pour toi c'est vraiment d'atouts
stratégiques que tu as utilisé dans le
développement de la société
au lancement on a été soutenue par les
habitants nordistes ont été soutenus par
les gens locale parce que il commandait
chez nous parce qu'il croyait à notre
projet ils veulent et consommer local et
du coup nous aussi de notre rang notre
retour aux commandes en hausse et on
consomme local du coup nous aussi on a
décidé aux dans notre structure que
vraiment tous nos consommations jusqu'à
dernier moment qu'on trouve pas un
prestataire local
après on pourra apporter de l'ex-star du
coup tous nos tee-shirts casquettes nous
ça cale et les sacs de livraison tous
tes productions locales même nos
véhicules et sont produits à
valenciennes sont aussi le local dit
qu'on n'a vraiment basé sur l'économie
locale parce qu'on sait très bien qu'on
consomme entre nous on pourra créer une
économie plus forte et créer un soutien
social et créer plus d'emplois c'est
très bien je pense qu'il ya encore
dernier élément humain dont tu voudrais
parler puisque l' aventure de fil me ce
n'est pas que toi c'est une autre
personne au site ont associé depuis y
ait de très longue date tu as un petit
mot pour lui pour terminer ouais c'est
enfin que juste mon associé c
c'est plus c'est mon cousin c'est mon
frangin c'est mon compagnon de route
c'est une relation de 27 ans on est
ensemble depuis l'âge de 3 ans on sait
jamais quitté et on a quelqu'un aux
parents pour
pour arriver ici ici c'est chez là c'est
grâce à lui et il est là
merci beaucoup et intérêts
merci